what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so one of the guys sent me a
message on actually I think it was a
youtube comment now I think about it um
but it was basically asking the question
about like the the Loki ruse from
infinity war I guess yeah from infinity
war and what role little play in
Avengers 4 so close you guys who don't
know what this means there's a fan
theory that's really been running around
for quite some time that Loki that Bruce
Banner was actually Loki the entire time
that it was basically a big trick um I
don't really think it was I think Bruce
Banner was actually Bruce Banner like I
think that's that's actually him but
there was a reddit post and I'll
actually have the link down in the
description
there was a reddit post that offered the
idea that Loki is actually alive and the
whole thing with Loki dying was
basically a trick that it was
essentially a ruse and that Loki is
still very much alive and is out there
somewhere and it really kind of begs the
question if that's true then one where
is he and two what's he doing that's
really kind of what this is what this
comes down to so the first question have
to ask ourselves is is Loki powerful
enough to create an illusion like that
because what you're doing is you're
talking about this massive scenario
unfolding whereby you have the Black
Order and you have tano's who were all
basically pummeling the Asgardians and
then you have like Loki there you know
and all the all these things taking
place and and it creates an interesting
scenario because if I were a betting man
if we had to go down this path of saying
that like Loki's actually alive then I
would say that everything you saw was
just to say like the environment of the
the ship and Asgard all that kind of
stuff all that stuff's there but like
Loki wasn't that in reality
Loki actually went with valkyrie like
like he went with them to keep them
protected because that breeze powerful
but she's not that powerful
she's like below Thor but she doesn't
really have like all the magical
abilities and things like that and so
low kick you just create kind of like a
projection of himself that exists on the
ship and an inter accident talks to
people in the whole nine yards and as
far as everyone's concerned including
Thor and in the whole nine yards like it
is low-key like Loki's you know Loki's
basically alive Heimdall would probably
see through it because Heimdall sees
everything with his eyes ah but again if
you're basically on the on the cusp of
saying like everyone's you know
everybody's basically dying are you
really gonna be the guy who spews out
but Loki's alive like I mean that's I
don't really you know then
didn't really jive with Heimdall's
character and so with that in mind if
that's the case I'll say for example
that Loki's with Valkyrie and he's with
like the other surviving as Guardians
I'd have a hard time believing Loki
would just be resting on his laurels
right he's just kind of like okay so
like who's up for a game of poker I
don't really see I mean it'd be funny
and it sounds like something Loki would
say but I don't really see that being as
character instead I actually see Loki
going out and doing things now this is
where things get really really
interesting for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because if we go by what we
know so far the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but at least Avengers 4 would
be a pretty basic film right like I
still stand by the idea that we're
basically gonna get Avengers forever
we're gonna get Avengers from the past
the present in the future which is away
from Marvel to bring it you know to kind
of bring back older characters it's a
way for Marvel to of course you know
have some whatever surviving member
members of the Avengers are left and
then give us a teaser of future
characters that we'll see I'm still
sticking by that theory although I could
be entirely wrong here
in all honesty with Loki being out there
the funny thing about this is that
people say well this was the only option
that we had this was the only choice
that we had but people assume that when
Doctor Strange said that Iron Man that
it was basically specifically for Iron
Man but like that may not be the case it
may have nothing to do with Iron Man so
if the Marvel Cinematic Universe goes
with Marvel Comics right like if they
they take this whole Marvel comic thing
and they roll it in there's a lot of
different things that we could go with
for example a Loki could basically do a
reverse acts of vengeance those you guys
who don't know what that is acts of
vengeance was like this huge story it
was like twelve or thirteen issues long
maybe was longer than that with all the
tie ins and everything but acts of
vengeance was basically old man Logan
before old man Logan if you don't know
what old man Logan is check out the
video I'll have it down in the
description but basically acts of
vengeance was Loki bringing all the
villains together but it was really for
the purpose of just like seating chaos
throughout the entirety of the Marvel of
the Marvel Universe just like causing
problems for for villains and for heroes
because Loki was a dick but like you
could easily see him doing that but
going to the realm of mistress death
like going to the realm of the Dead we
don't know if mistress death actually
exists but like if hella is really dead
and like she was the stand-in for
mistress death then what it means right
now is the realm of the Dead has no
leader there's no one running the show
out there it's just all these dead
people roaming around and it would
basically mean like there's no
gatekeeper and so you could have people
leave the realm of the dead and if
that's possible locate you just go there
you just go to there go to the realm of
Hell where where hell it was and just be
like okay so I need like red skull I
need this guy this guy this guy this guy
and this guy like all these different
people and I need to bring them all back
and they're they're gonna show up for
kind of like one last hurrah they could
easily go with that idea it really kind
of depends because then if they decided
they wanted to invoke the idea of death
well then you get into a whole new
kettle of beans so we've had this
conversation before we've talked about
this kind of thing before so back when
four first showed up in Marvel when you
had Stanley Jack Kirby and Thor made his
debut and journey into mystery going
forward until journey into mystery
became his own solo series what you had
was the main story itself the main
adventures of Thor and then you had
backup features basically meaning like
four page stories that were at the very
back of the comic there were at the very
end passed like the end page for the for
the journey into mystery and these were
called tales of Asgard and it was a way
for a writer really I guess Jack Kirby
was the one who wrote it so for writer
and artist Jack Kirby to basically tell
like the whole history of Asgard before
Thor showed up you know I'm sorry before
before Thor landed on earth and even
some of the things that were going on in
Asgard when Thor you know while he was
on earth learning who he was and
discovering his power as being a
superhero so on and so forth so that by
the time you were reading journey into
mystery and Thor went to Asgard for the
first time you knew all this backlog I
hear all this backstory the origins and
how the frost giants came into existence
and how the odinforce works and where
Odin got it from and all that kind of
cool stuff and so when is up happening
here is that in this whole scenario you
just had like hella
and that was it and essentially the way
the afterlife worked was all beings who
die go to the realm of hell the only
exception to that is those who die an
honorable combat in which case Odin sins
the Valkyries they take their spirits
they bring him to Valhalla and they
spend the rest of the rest of eternity
talking about how awesome it was they
cut a guy's head off once and like
that's it like that's that's that's all
that's all they know happening fast
forward in 1968 Steve Englehart
introduced Mephisto in Silver Surfer I
think and then fast forward to 1973 when
jim Starlin introduced mistress death he
introduces mistress death and
Captain Marvel number 26 and in the
whole base is behind this this is
basically saying like there's different
after lives now I mean what you end up
having with the realm of Mephisto is
actual health
heo hell and it was basically a place
that you go when you make a bargain with
Mephisto because and he takes your soul
when you die then you actually have the
realm of mistress death the realm of
death proper which is basically where
everyone goes except for those who
believe in the Asgardian mythos and then
of those who believe in the Asgardian
mythos those who died in honorable
combat go to Valhalla everybody else
they just go to hell they I'm sorry they
just go to to the realm of the Dead and
even then there's different depictions
on how it's done like you go read Chris
Claremont uncanny x-men Jean Grey's is
in a room with all these pillars and you
end up finding out that each pillar is
an afterlife for a particular person who
died and then that was changed later on
were turned out each one of those
pillars stood for like one of the five
billion people who were destroyed by
Jean Grey when she was a Dark Phoenix
it's weird she was a white Phoenix of
the crown yada yada so on and so forth
you got a wreak response Evan teen year
on order understand it's kind of a crazy
situation but what this means is that
for the character of Loki there's ample
places he can go to and ample locations
that that we can basically visit with
him in order to see like the much bigger
Marvel Cinematic Universe now aside from
that there's various other options as
well there's like the library of worlds
that he could go to by Jonathan Hickman
we already have the Black Order all you
need now are like the black swans so if
those are guys who don't know in Marvel
Comics way back in the day you had a
villain named the molecule man Owen
Reese and he was pretty straightforward
he was just a guy who had a wand and he
could perform you know little bits of
magic and you know kind of change
reality I'm like a super small scale so
like he could turn like an apple into a
teapot or something like that and that
was about the extent of it fast-forward
to 1984 when when Jim shooter wrote
Secret Wars and what you ended up
finding out was that molecule and Owen
Reese could do a whole lot more it's
just he had these mental blocks in place
because he had no confidence and so
Doctor Doom basically removed those
mental blocks and he was elevated to the
realm of God fast-forward 40 years or
something like that you know and you
basically end up having Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers
where you end up finding out the
experiment that led to you know molecule
man getting his powers was universal
across every universe and every single
universe has ever existed in the history
of Marvel Comics molecule man was
working for a corporation molecule man
performed an experiment the experiment
went awry
he opened a portal ^ beyonders got one
half of their power the other half
became something else floated out there
became the Beyonder or whatever but that
always happens in every single universe
and the reason why is because the ivory
Kings the beyonders themselves were
actually performing this grand
experiment and they were going to
detonate all the molecule man across the
multiverse and wipe out the multiverse
innocent higher the result was that dr.
doom figured out what was going on they
ended up killing one of the molecule man
by accident it created a cascading
effect in the multiverse sort of
collapsing anyway so it gets kind of
crazy but the fact remains here um when
it comes to this whole Jonathan Hickman
you know the black order and and all
that kind of good stuff
you had something called the library of
worlds and the library of worlds was was
literally like this dimension that was
created by the beyonders whereby every
other universe could be accessed from it
but it had different rooms inside of it
and in one room there was like there
were no words in another room you had
like you know all this lost knowledge on
magic and sorcery and all these
different things and you have the actual
private quarters of a room allall
himself which was turned out to be
Doctor Doom he had all these different
things that that took place you know
with with this particular location but
what I'm saying here is that there's a
there's other realms at other dimensions
he can visit like look he could go there
to the library of worlds and learn like
this is the one piece of magic I need in
order to defeat you know Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet or to save the day or
something along those lines my money is
on the fact that Loki is actually dead
like Loki's gone like I'm a suit like
look he's probably gone for forever um
but again you could also go with this I
mean there's there's all kinds of
options that are available to us it
could be that he's just like
dimension-hopping right just like
jumping from dimension to dimension and
we'll see like Moon Knight and we'll see
all these different the various
superheroes who are out there because
look he's been jumping from reality to
reality and grabbing them ah there's
there's all kinds of scenarios that can
unfold here I mean there's any number of
things that can take place we really
don't know I mean literally like I would
I would say before Infinity Ward came
out I would have told you I have a
pretty good idea of what direction this
is gonna go in but like infinity war
ended where Infinity Gauntlet ended
basically I mean there's a couple of
things that change there's a couple more
things but like for the most part if
they were to take the second the second
half you know the second act of Infinity
Gauntlet and they were to turn that into
Avengers for the movie would be over
like the cat it would be the quickest
film ever it would be like
and nebula takes a gauntlet done and
like that's it like that's that's all
that you would get but I imagine this
could be a whole lot more with like all
these different things that go on and so
like that by the way spoilers for a
story that came out in 1982 so
nonetheless you know it is it's it's
crazy it's it's it's cut it's kind of
wild I mean there's so many things that
you can go at so many things that you
can do in this whole this this whole MCU
especially with Loki because well he's
not as powerful as Doctor Strange in the
comics I mean not as powerful as classic
Doctor Strange modern-day Doctor Strange
definite like he's actually probably
more powerful to be honest until Doctor
Strange became Jesus those are guys who
read the most recent story about chips
at RSP
he basically becomes Jesus like he
absorbs all the power of the World Tree
in Asgard and then he's just like he's
just like Jesus power then he's just
like oh you know the power of Doctor
Strange compels you and this is it's
it's funny but uh but anyway yeah is if
there's there's so many things you can
do here in so many directions they can
go in for the character of Loki but
again all that hinges on the idea that
Loki survived again I'm going under the
assumption of Loki's debt that he's gone
like he's you know it was a huge tragic
moment about like Loki's essentially out
of the picture he's no longer there
because if it really was all an illusion
when Loki was killed I've been in
reality like he would have just kind of
faded away but then again in the comics
look when Loki cast his spell the spell
stays there so long as he wants it to or
until it gets to a point where he's so
exhausted he can't maintain it anymore
but just creating a facsimile of himself
in the form of like a holographic
illusion basically but not be that
taxing I mean especially when you're
talking about him creating like a whole
set inside of the cell and Thor - so I
don't know let me really guys stay down
in the comments section I'm kind of
curious I think it's a cool theory and I
think it's a really really good idea um
and on the surface it works but I
imagine if we if we were to really
really get into this and like start
researching the heck out of it we could
probably find some audibles but at the
end of the day like I just like talking
about theories I think it's just fun to
theorize about crazy ideas and topics
and things like that so anyway guys if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rod core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]